Hello! Welcome to Michael's Business Top Tips.
This month, we're looking at mind mapping.
Now, this is an easy and great technique you can use for a variety of business situations.
How does it work? Very simple.
First, you put the topic or issue, or situation in the center of a page or on a whiteboard.
So, for example, let's take marketing.
Then, you draw a circle around it.
And then, you brainstorm other ideas or topics connected with this.
For example, maybe TV commercials...
...or maybe magazine articles, or commercial adverts,...
...or maybe Internet.
Then, the next step is to further brainstorm ideas.
So these could be maybe by sending e-mails to customers...
...or maybe again advertising, et cetera.
This is so useful because it is a very quick way to generate ideas.
A nice variant on this is to use Post-its.
If you're doing a brainstorming meeting,...
...try having the people each write one idea on a Post-it.
Then, put the Post-its on the whiteboard and organize using this mind mapping structure.
This is a very quick and easy way to get lots of ideas and then, organizing clearly.
Mind mapping can be used for brainstorming.
It can be used for notes taking.
It can be used for problem solving.
Many different situations.
I always use it when I'm writing my AERA English articles...
...and it helps me a lot.
Okay. Next month, we're gonna look at an issue that's key to many people, time management.
See you then!